Les mains sur nos cœurs,
front contre front,
nous étions en communion dans le mouvement et la musique,
faisant sens de ce qui n’en avait pas.
Bella a 83 ans et vit avec la démence.
La danse nous offre l’occasion de nous trouver.
Comment ai-je appris à danser avec la démence ?
Car je ne suis pas danseur.
Ni médecin.
Mais j’en ai joué le rôle dans un hôpital.
(Il rit)
Je suis un clown médecin.
Un clown médical en quelque sorte.
Dans mon attirail, il y a des coussins péteurs,
des maracas,
(Bruit des maracas)
et un nez rouge.
Vous connaissez tous le vieil adage que le rire est le meilleur des remèdes.
On me le répète souvent.
Des études le prouvent scientifiquement
et je vais vous emmener dans les coulisses du nez rouge et du rire
et vous relater quelques aventures en patins à roulettes dans les urgences.
Sur des talons aiguilles.
Pointure 45.
Car je prends le métier de clown médical
très, très au sérieux.
(Pétarade)
(Rires)
Mon mentor faisait le clown dans un hôpital
quand une infirmière l’a abordé.
Ils devaient poser un tube dans le nez d’un gosse.
Mais il ne voulait pas.
Alors, ils ont demandé notre aide
plutôt que de restreindre l’enfant.
Le clown a demandé un deuxième tube
et il l’a enfoncé dans son nez.
Un peu comme ceci.
Ne faites jamais ça à la maison !
(Rires)
Quand le gosse a vu ça,
il a empoigné son tube
et l’a mis dans son nez rapidement.
Un peu comme ça.
(Applaudissements)
Le clown, l’infirmière et le patient
venaient de découvrir ensemble une solution créative à leur problème.
Et vous savez quoi ? La science étaye cela.
Des tests aléatoires effectués en Israël et en Italie
montrent que les clowns médicaux agissent autant que les tranquillisants
mais sans effets secondaires.
J’ai commencé mes propres tournées de clown en 2004
au Centre du Cancer Memorial Sloan Kettering à New York.
Mon collègue et moi avions été conviés à accompagner un enfant de 6 ans
à l’accent doux du sud,
pendant qu’on nettoyait le cathéter de sa chimiothérapie.
C’est une procédure standard mais inconfortable.
On l’a rejoint avec sa maman et l’infirmière
dans une petite cellule fermée.
Chaque première rencontre avec un clown médical
commence par un consentement.
Nous lui avons demandé si nous pouvions rester.
Il a dit oui.
Nous sommes souvent le seul élément qu’un enfant peut contrôler
quand il est hospitalisé.
On a d’abord fait un tour de cartes.
Il a choisi une carte.
Mais quand l’infirmière s’est approchée avec l’aiguille
pour nettoyer le cathéter,
il s’est mis à crier et jurer ;
je n’avais jamais entendu ça dans la bouche d’un gamin.
Alors on lui a proposé de revenir plus tard.
Il s’est arrêté, bouche bée,
les yeux en larmes, le visage cramoisi par la rage
et il a souri :
« Non, vous, ça va, restez, s’il vous plait. »
OK.
Alors on a joué une chanson,
mon collègue avec un enregistreur et moi avec un coussin péteur.
L’infirmière vient avec l’aiguille,
et rebelote, le torrent d’injures.
Il passait du jeu et du rire
aux cris et aux larmes
tour à tour, jusqu’à la fin de la procédure.
C'était la première fois que j’étais le témoin
de cette dualité étrange de joie et de souffrance.
Ce ne fut pas la dernière.
Notre présence n’est pas uniquement pour distraire
ou pour que les gens se sentent mieux.
Les clowns médicaux travaillent un moment à la fois
pour créer un lien entre les clowns,
les infirmières, les parents et les enfants.
Ça contribue à gérer l’enfant
tout en apportant un soutien au personnel dans leur travail.
Ça fait plus de dix ans que j’apporte joie et émerveillement
au chevet d’enfants en fin de vie
dans les plus grands hôpitaux de New York.
Savez-vous ce que j’ai appris ?
Tout le monde a mal.
Le personnel, les familles, les patients.
Les patients hospitalisés car ils souffrent.
La famille souffre, plongée dans l’incertitude, le chagrin,
et le poids financier des soins.
Le personnel souffre, mais bien plus qu’un burn-out.
De plus en plus de personnel hospitalier
disent se sentir surchargés et à bout.
Je ne suis pas naïf au point de suggérer
que les clowns sont la solution.
(Rires)
Mais, et si ?
Et si les tours des clowns médicaux et des artistes du monde entier
imprégnaient tout notre système de santé ?
À la conférence internationale des clowns de santé de 2018,
on a présenté plus de 150 programmes issus de 50 pays.
L’université de Haïfa
propose une formation diplômante en clownerie médicale.
L’Argentine a passé une loi qui exige la présence de clowns médicaux
dans les hôpitaux publics des plus grandes provinces.
Ça ne concerne pas que les patients.
Ça améliore la situation pour toute l’équipe médicale.
Un de mes jeux préférés dans un hôpital,
c'est la musique d’ascenseur.
J’adore les ascenseurs car c’est l’endroit
où les chemins se croisent, où différents mondes se rencontrent.
C’est intime,
empreint d’un silence gêné
et en attente impatiente d’une petite distraction.
Dès que la porte se ferme,
« The Girl of Ipanema » joué au synthé retentit
grâce à mon ampli portable caché dans une poche.
Pour ceux qui sont familiers des ascenseurs silencieux et stériles,
c’est la surprise !
Les passagers peuvent réagir ou pas à cette perturbation.
Le jeu s’amplifie étage après étage
car à chaque arrêt,
la musique s’arrête.
D’autres personnes entrent
et les passagers déjà présents observent les nouveaux arrivants,
et la surprise sur leur visage avec la musique.
On observe le glissement des adultes,
debout et silencieux, des étrangers dans un ascenseur,
qui essaient de contenir leur hilarité
à : « Il y a une nouba dans l’ascenseur »
pleine de rires.
Des études au Brésil,
en Australie, au Canada et en Allemagne
confirment que les interventions artistiques des clowns médicaux
améliorent l’environnement de travail au-delà de l’ascenseur,
et soutiennent l’administration des soins.
Des recherches aux États-Unis indiquent
que les programmes artistiques dans les hôpitaux
améliorent l’environnement de travail,
augmentent la satisfaction
et contribuent à une meilleure qualité de soins.
Mon travail m’a appris comment être vraiment présent.
Comment respirer en présence d'une personne qui souffre.
Comment me connecter
et construire la confiance, quel que soit l’âge, la capacité ou la maladie.
Et combien les clowns médicaux utilisent habilement les arts
pour remettre le soin au cœur de la santé.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)